you dress like [__] so [__] off your
mother we try to do everything as real
as possible so anytime there's a
physical scene I get punched in the face
I got punched in the face for real truth
is I I said to Jonah before we started I
said hey look man smart and Scorsese
movie man right I'ma slap you first of
all wasn't a punch it wasn't it was just
a slap okay you know I said just let me
slap you and as soon as the scene's over
slap me back off camera you can smack
the [__] out of me it's [__] Scorsese
he just uh it it wasn't something he was
totally into at the time uh it wasn't
looking quite real and Scorsese asked if
I would take one in the face for real
and I did
and then I think it was really Leo who
who sort of stepped up and said you know
I think you guys should do it for real
and and Jonah you know he he he was
Brave man he said okay you know this is
going to be the real punch everybody and
I want everyone to be you know they were
ready with like an ice pack and [__]
like that right and he broke his teeth
this is fake teeth Martin Score says he
asked me to do anything for this
character I would have done it and I
pretty much do